[Musique]
première émission des jeux de 20h nous
jouons avec bordeaux bonsoir bordeaux
bonsoir jean pierre un bien bon soir
jackson laisse beaucoup de monde en
effet d'un autre studio de notre station
régionale bordeaux d'ailleurs ils vont
faire un petit peu de bruit pour bien
convaincus sont tous là voilà qu'ils ont
déjà été sélectionnés ils sont prêts à
jouer de nombreux nombreux jeux sont en
pleine forme et nous avons dans lol par
contre d'autres candidats qui attendent
d'être sélectionné en compagnie de dan
et d'obélix andres elle bat dominique
bonsoir jacques ça va très bien
d'ailleurs vous allez entendre la voix
de mes bordelais parfait tout va bien
dominique quand on va bien nous sommes
prêts également dans le studio ce soir
nos candidats vont jouer avec micheline
dax bonsoir micheline avec jan valtin
hautes études et applaudit lui même la
nouvelle robert rocca et laure là
maintenant un grand moment de cette
émission je vous demande un peu de
silence un peu de recueillement je vous
présente maître capello si si si si
c'est lui même quatre lots arbitre du
beau langage trésorier et juge unique de
cette émission
maître capello candidats de bordeaux
maître capello a sélectionné pour vous
une phrase d'un auteur connu cette
phrase vous allez devoir la reconstituer
en fin d'émission mais pour avoir le
droit de la reconstituer vous allez
subir quelques épreuves préliminaires
cette phrase nous la regardons ensemble
elle vaut mille francs pour l'instant
elle comporte 8 mo le lait est et est
bien entendu cinq autres mou et chaque
candidat qui trouvera un mot de cette
phrase est bien fera augmenter la valeur
de cette phrase de 1000 francs donc pour
l'instant elle vaut mille francs nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure et nous
espérons que les candidats vont faire
grossir la valeur de ces trois et on
pourra empocher le contenu du petit
cochon rose de jacques capelovici qui
est ici si vous avez des idées mais
chelem jean-robert surtout ne vous gênez
pas tout à leur fédération de volley de
membres voilà et bien pour l'instant
commençons notre sélection avec un
premier jeu
[Applaudissements]
dominique oui voilà la candidate est en
place à ce que je vois oui c'était les
jolies florence va-t-on lui demander son
prénom
non pardon florès un geste une jolie
soeur de catherine m'excuser j'avais
compris fleurs fleurs à vos soirées et
bien florence vous avez lu ce matin dans
le journal sud ouest le mot calumet au
pluriel comme celui qui est affichée là
bien entendu et nous avons eu tout le
temps de vous préparer maintenant
micheline dax va tenter de vous faire
deviner un mot issu des lettres de
calumet en vous proposant une définition
de son cru nous sommes bien d'accord
oui bien alors attention nous jouons
pour deux minutes top chrono
michel 7 alors florent je vais tout de
suite commencer par un mot difficile
parce que je suis très méchant je vais
prendre un mot de six lettres carrément
ça vous gêne page 1 non pas du tout
alors à moins de six lettres et je vous
dis ceux de charlie chaplin ont fait de
l'or ont fait de leur une autre
définition
alors je vous dis dangereux sur la route
laurence dangereux sur la route
combien de lettres si la str6 également
une troisième définition alors toujours
au pluriel casse toujours quand on est
pressé
grâce au toujours comme on est pressé
alors attention jeu 2-3 florent je suis
désolé vous n'êtes pas sélectionné mais
vous gagnez tout de même deux places de
cinéma gratuites dans un cinéma de votre
choix à bordeaux un candidat cellou
qu'elle allait à vau s'il vous plaît des
lacets des l'art c'est bien non
un autre candidat est en place oui bien
sûr madame votre non madame keller alors
un mot de trois lettres madame son
histoire a défrayé la chronique
son histoire a défrayé la chronique
une autre définition micheline la
réponse coule de source madame nac nac
non non sauf le pain une autre lot
willow oui madame vous êtes sélectionné
bravo vous avez terminé jean pierre et
vous avez d'ores et déjà gagné 53
bonsoir très vite une autre définition
pour essayer deux alors un mot de trois
lettres il peut être gros ouf un autre
définition on ne souffle pas peut-être
alors une autre de within the lady
l'esprit n'en manque pas top c'est
terminé et bien je suis désolé jeune
homme
nous avons terminé le temps qui était un
parti comme le jeu vous allez me donner
le bon bien sûr il faut des idées des
lumières c'est le sel c'est le sel bien
entendu et bien un maître nous allons
sélectionner je crois ainsi une seule
personne qui tout à l'heure en fin
d'émission participera à la fin à la
phrase de maître capello
merci micheline vous avez parfaitement
jouer je vous félicite c'est tout
après de dominique que cendres elle
passons maintenant à notre deuxième
jean-pierre oui nous sommes prêts
jacques qui nous vous écoutons ce
bordelais a vécu une aventure que nous
vous demandons de retrouver nous l'avons
masqué car la vue de son visage pourrait
aider et micheline dax robert au cas où
jan valtin alors à vous de jouer
merci jean pierre bonne chance monsieur
micheline jean robert et vous avez
compris vous devez envoyer quelle
aventure vous avez l'habitude alors
attention trois minutes top chrono c'est
parti alors monsieur c'est une aventure
qui vous est arrivé
oui bien un bien en demandant d'autres
détails
c'est une aventure récente très récente
une aventure sportive
oui à une aventure désagréable fort
désagréable dont vous êtes sorti blessé
meurtri dans votre personne physique en
temps non morale plutôt monsieur pas
trop d'état je vous en prie c'est oui ou
non ils vont nous disais oui ou non mais
si oui aventure sportive je suis dans le
domaine de l'aviation
non la boxe nous dans l'automobile non
l'athlétisme noms de la natation
non les dominos nous d'être bons non
mais cette mésaventure nous a laissé une
mauvaise impression parce que vous avez
perdu
oui vous avez perdu seul contre beaucoup
je n'étais pas seul est ce que c'est un
sport individuel non à le rugby chine au
niveau master il reste 1 on après
football vous avez marqué contre votre
camp
non ne répondez surtout monsieur que par
oui vous avez bien de faire mais je le
sens il est tout près gardien jeu
non arbitres ne nous faisiez partie de
l'équipe sur le terrain
oui vous avez perdu votre culotte
vous avez perdu votre pull over flottant
ça s'appelle je crois non non ça avait
déculottée à l'adversaire non non plus
vous avez vu confisquer le ballon
déculottée larbitre j'aurais aimé oui
mais oui
pas d'indication monsieur vous avez été
un insolent avec l' arbitre même pas
c'est lui qui a été insolent avec vous
mais non vous avez été disqualifié wii
sorti du terrain à ce alors il faut
servir sortie du terrain ou disqualifier
sortie du terrain bon pendant le match
oui à bras le corps oui il avait
embrassé l'herbe y en a qui aiment bah
oui alors répondez oui ou non non non
non non c'est lui qui vous et les
propositions malhonnêtes que vous avez
quartier presque west ward là où l'ue
ailleurs vous avez blessés l'arbite dans
son amour propre et dans le mien
répondez par oui non non c est vous avez
quitté le terrain à la première mi temps
non est ce que j'ai le terrain avec
l'arbitrage on est ce que vous allez
quitter le terrain avec l'arbitré n'a
pas voulu à suivre il a plu aux jeunes
arbitres était une femme
doc c'est terminé et bien vous n'avez
pas trouvé n'ose le secret de ce
monsieur la voiture qui lui est arrivé
je viens de dire exactement ce qui lui
est arrivé je vous le dire avant qu'il
ne retire son masque
car lorsqu'il va avoir retiré son masque
vous allez bien sûr le reconnaître ce
monsieur est entré sur un terrain dans
un match de coupe de france de football
et on est ressorti deux minutes après
mais sans toucher le bal avez vous
deviné de qui il s'agit alors montrez
votre visage car là vraiment il sèche
lamentablement
voilà et vous nous donnez vous nous
rappelez plus exactement votre nom
didier couécou
didier couécou qui a eu maille à partir
entre dans un match de coupe de france
entre nice je crois et bordeaux c'est
bien cela oui malheureusement
bon et maintenant comment ça se passe eh
bien je crois que j'ai eue de la
commission de discipline
j'ai vu ce que j'ai voulu c'est à dire
qu'un seul match de suspension parce que
ils ont compris que je n'avais rien fait
mais malheureusement dans les règlements
il ya automatiquement un match et ils ne
veulent pas malgré les films d'affaires
3 ils ne veulent pas entendre parler de
blanchissages
on pourrait bien je crois qu'on peut
applaudir didier migaud qui a
parfaitement joué à mis en échec
merci didier couécou vous pouvez
maintenant si vous le voulez participer
à la phrase de capello tout à l'heure en
fin d'émission vous pouvez aussi tenter
votre chance il ya pour l'instant cent
mille anciens fonds a gagné et nous
allons tout de suite retourné auprès de
dominique cendres elle dominique vous
êtes nous allons rejouer pendant deux
minutes à notre petit jeu si je vous dis
est la voie la régie janval temps qui va
jouer alors attention jour nous sommes
prêts pour deux minutes
le premier candidat j'affiche lebon
halle aux veaux monsieur jour monsieur
monsieur dites moi en quatre lettres
voilà la définition je vous donne quand
il est petit on le voit mieux avec des
lentilles quand il est petit on le voit
mieux avec des lentilles un deuxième une
deuxième fille sarah n'est pas mon cas
mais avec un accent ou sans accent il
est épicé alors une autre définition
gens s'il vous plaît et si je vous ai
tandis que ce que je voulais comme haute
définition badoit et si je vous dis que
c'est un rapport avec un lac monsieur
d'amérique clash la station alors croire
monsieur vous êtes éliminé les places de
pardon ça laisse aller sa les places de
synovate et avec elles avec des
lentilles optiques c'est bon et à
bonjour aux gens madame je vous donne
également un mot de quatre lettres mois
un mot de quatre lettres si je vous dis
que pour l'automobiliste
c'est l'arbre le plus utile deuxième
définition gens bon si je vous dis que
son transport n'est dangereux
le gas gas annonce 3 et metal est madame
4 et bien si vous n'oubliez pas attendu
non
n'oubliez pas les ont si vous voulez
changer de couleur gille c'était cam la
maternité la galilée ou un autre
candidat s'il vous plaît très vite
décidément nous avons beaucoup à les
sélectionner bon bon ça fait très
attention là si je vous dis première
définition
si je vous dis que bien que la puce en
trois lettres et s'il peut se permettre
de changer de femme comme deux voyelles
vous ne voyez pas les bons finisseurs si
je vous dis maintenant à la manière de
coluche
alors je vais vous raconter son histoire
oui c'était m ou mac mec oumma bravo
monsieur vous gagnez 50 sont les vite
retrouver jean-pierre pour le jeu final
il est dans le sud elle vous attend la
candidate était en pleine montée de bien
vouloir donner ça mais alors que victor
cause il est trop raide très vite alors
si je vous dis madame que sa compagne un
succès d'edith piaf quoi l'être madame
edith piaf voulez vous répéter la
question cette dame n'a pas son temps
dit je vous dis qu en trois lettres
s'accompagne d'un succès d'edith piaf
madame en problème si je vous dis par
exemple madame il faut mais pas en
abuser
il faut temps mais pas en abuser et si
je vous dis à la fin que ça s'accompagne
souvent de jusqu'à la corde en trois
lettres ou madame donc un réseau l'essai
refusé le disque externe
et bien nous avons sélectionné je crois
trois candidats trois candidats
jusqu'ici et nous allons maintenant
passer à notre troisième
micheline voulez vous vous retournez je
vous prie c'est une joie et vous allez
maintenant regarder surtout noté la
phrase que vous propose c'est aux dames
bonsoir madame bonsoir monsieur l voilà
vous noté surtout line je vous hais
cette avance vous devrez tout à l'heure
la placer dans une histoire dont je vous
donnerai le départ c'est comme si vous
l'aviez laissée sans que j'en ressens la
perçoit bien ces attentions gens à votre
tour et veuillez noter la phrase 20
autres candidats de bordeaux très vite
ses douleurs aux jambes au labour soir
méfier les bordelais a mis des mots
assez d'humour
ces faits gens vous l'avez nôtre c'est
fait parfait le robert à votre tour
retournez vous ai noté cette troisième
phrase présenté par un troisième
candidat de bordeaux d'autres nombreux
lacs et facile à placer dans une
conversation oui c'est très facile à
placer dans une conversation voilà on
retire les phrases s'il vous plaît
retournez vous retournez vous maintenant
voilà vers nous et je demande que l'on
atteigne l'écran de contrôle qui se
trouve devant nos amis de façon à ce
qu'il ne puisse pas voir les frasques
l'affiché tout à l'heure et bien je vous
propose tout simplement d'essayer
maintenant de placer chacun la phrase
que vous avez noté dans une conversation
à bâtons rompus je vous reconnais je
vais vous donner le départ d'une
histoire une histoire veilleurs qui
était qu un rapport avec l'actualité
écoutez bien malgré leur passion commune
pour le camembert la princesse ginette
et son mari lorsque au bout tu as avait
décidé de se séparer car micheline fin
car justement le mari violent ça où tu
détestais le camembert brusquement
c'était une énergie qui m'était venu
comme ça bêtement
il adore et le camembert sous-vêtements
off est alors en même temps l'allergie
avec l'avait conduit à détester aussi sa
part parce que c'était une énergie
communicative
alors une fois qu'il a été privé de la
dame et du camembert
et bien voilà il est devenu il est
devenu dresseur de fauves il a commencé
par dresser les asticots qui avait
contenu dans le camembert d'une part et
puis ensuite il est est un budget
extrêmement violent le lors de son but
était extrêmement violent
il avait toujours un fou et un fouet sa
femme ne met pas toujours ça mais lui il
souhaitait par exemple il faut être sans
arrêt par exemple quand il traverse et
montélimar
ils fouettaient des nougats c'était dur
mais c'est à dire ils fouettaient deluga
mais aussi il faut dire que tout le
malheur conjugale de ce ménage était
venue de là une nuit
l'amant de la princesse ginette avait
été surpris par son mari et l'amant
avait dû s'enfuir et pour s'enfuir il
avait dû traverser une rivière à la nage
qu'à un sauvage avait précédé qui avait
fait sauter le pont il faut dire c'était
une espèce de kanaks et et réducteurs de
têtes de pont dans son boulot d'ailleurs
il était le patron et aidante réducteur
en chef ah oui la 16e entendu et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'elle elle était
devenue à ce moment là elle s'était
naturalisé russe
cette princesse parce qu'elle voulait
fuir son mari à tout prix et poursuivre
le kanak elle était venue 10 à régaler
de savoir pourquoi vous savez les femmes
décident et moi qui suis je m'écoutais
je vous dirais aussi ce que je suis
devenu alors cette darin cette 7e art
inné c'est arrivé enfin elle a abandonné
très vite ce dresseur de fauves parce
que naturel nouvelle précise aussi comme
il avait dressé sa femme alors qu'il
s'intéressait particulièrement aux
animaux des animaux russe d'ailleurs les
animaux par exemple ils dressaient il
dressait au tollé il avait dressé je me
souviens herlant
il avait dressé aussi sa tante dans sur
le bord de la rivière là dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure et sur laquelle
je reviens parce que la proximité de ce
paysage l'amant avait une vieille que
parents à lui qui avait été femme tronc
et qui avaient liquidé sa baraque
foraine il s'était placé dans une église
sans une église où aller prier lazzari
de régulièrement car elle était restée
quand même très pieuse malgré ces
avatars
alors un jour qu'elle était en route
pour aller dans cette église prier cette
malheureuse darid tombe en panne alors
elle rencontre le sauvage qui habitait
une près comme vous l'avez je suppose
noté et elle va demander poliment à ce
qu'on pouvait s'il me dépanner alors ce
garçon mais voilà justement ce gars est
à fond c'est à dire toi y aller chez le
dentiste
c'est là leur essor le meilleur dresseur
d'ailleurs cdt le thé dresseur il était
dresseurs d'animaux ils redresseur de
torts c'est bien qu'il doublait en même
temps et il avait je vous disais ce
merlan c'est bien d'un incendie
messieurs berlin extraordinaire qu'était
un coiffeur remarquable car moi j'ai été
coiffeur pour dames et je vous
raconterai ça un jour que je ne saurais
pas quoi vous dire ce qui est pas mon
cas ce soir est donc ce coiffeur alors
tout bêtement lui a dit écoutez madame
le sauvage n'est pas là parce qu'il ait
pas de service aujourd'hui mémoire je
peux vous rendre service et savez c'est
fou quand même
alors c'est le hasard parce que ça c'est
vraiment pas préparé
c'était le hasard total uli madame je
suis à vous le merlan dont je tenais à
vous entretenir de pâques et bien qu'il
avait un bâton de vanille entre les
dents il ressemblait un bolchevik
c'était très amusant parce que quand tu
as passé en russie
alors il avait donc dressé sommairement
il avait dressé également il avait
dressé aussi que s'il y avait dressé il
avait dressé une longue liste modem dans
ce précédent vous être est à suivre
oui j'aimerais me reparler de ce kanak
oui on vous paraissait avoir perdu la
piste faut dire que le kanak avait
parfaitement réussi la fin de sa vie il
avait collectionné les têtes de pont
qu'il avait réduite il avait installé
dans un grand terrain ils savent allier
et on a fait ça les aliments kanak est
oui alors justement communauté relation
jour là le coiffeur a dit madame qu'est
ce que peut faire brute de la tsarine à
échanger tout bêtement sans voir hier
contre une trop barazer forcément
puisque c'était à quoi pensez-vous qu'il
avait
alors à ce moment-là lazzari lui a dit
écoutez j'arriverai à écouter qu'est ce
que devient toujours ce merlan parce
qu'elle était obsédée notre série de
lumières demande à bord c'est cette
faille très fréquents en russie
et alors il a vu le meilleur non mais
c'est le merlot et ma femme est allé de
même ma femme est allée chercher des
huîtres ce matin et pourtant elle était
faite aux moules le client s'asseyant
dans le fauteuil du maire là on lui dit
je voudrais changer donc soit une riley
lui a fait d'ailleurs il lui a fait une
règle médiane mais alors elle moule et
s'assure aussi lazzari est alors comme
elle avait l'habitude de stations sur un
pouf en tôle est là comment ça s'appelle
en tôle ondulée elle dit m'écoutais je
ne peux pas m'asseoir ici il n'ya pas un
siège digne de moi j'ai l'habitude
d'être sur un procès ça sur un trône est
en général d'ailleurs elle l'était
encore reçu près soudan elle voulait pas
stationner son carrousel cause des
aubergines donc y avait déjà des
auberges ans à cette époque là est
grande et la rampe
oui alors quand elle a rencontré
peut-être quand elle a rencontré quoi
lasser
l'afrique a transformé l aubergine vous
voulez ça fait une histoire
extraordinaire que d'ailleurs nous
savons que je vais vous raconter ça une
façon je vais vous le résumé c'était
alors la de n'oublier pas lazzari parce
que c'est important quand même pour le
récit le kanak lui écrivait desmoudt
billets qu'elle ne pouvait pas lire
forcément savait pas écrire à dire non
et alors que l'aubergine qui était venu
habiter dans le palais royal
eh bien elle s'est éprise d'un amour fou
le guen pour la langue hausse seulement
la langouste el benian et la girafe
paient la girafe montre aussi qu'il y
avait
engagé un certain frais abbas en savait
pas ce qu'elle disait comme comme tout
le monde le sait vont le faire ou non -
pays elle agira plutôt que faire des
bêtises
et c'est à ce moment là qu'elle s'est
mariée avec le kanak était revenu et oui
elle peut y en a elles paient et il
agira sans botter quelques paniers les
loups les langues les toilettes
spéciales des aubergines envers aussi un
point très important pour elle parce que
oui c'est bien je pense que c'est
terminé maintenant nous allons un peu
éclaircir cette histoire qui me semble
assez embrouillée aux non jeûneurs pas
du tout un bon accord très bien je vous
demande et micheline quelle phrase
devait prononcer robert jeu vouloir que
c'était il était redresse il était
réducteurs de têtes de pont il était
réducteurs de têtes de pont mais qui
serait réducteur de tête de pont mais
ces poissons kanak sont kanak et
maintenant j'en quelle phrase devait
prononcer micheline dubois a fait un vol
alors leçon gens les ont tendance à
noyer inscrire probert qu'elle fera je
n'ai pas retenu la formulation exacte
parce que j'en parle à une vitesse
incroyable et je pense que ça tourne
autour de l'idée qu'il avait dressé un
merlan qu'il avait adressé à mes retenu
agresseurs de merlan et de langoustes
voilà eh bien je pense que nous n'avons
qu'une seule gagnante c'est micheline
qui a réussi à placer sa phrase sans que
ses adversaires s'en aperçoive
et c'est donc la chine qui fait gagner à
l'auteur de cette phrase qui était je le
rappelle lazzari n'échangent à son point
hier contre une bombe à raser il faut
réussir à le faire quand même voilà
qu'elle avait à peu près normale
micheline assidus le bordelais auteur
donc ça comprend un peu de discipline
s'il vous plaît l'auteur de cette phrase
je gagne donc 50 francs et la sa
sélection pour la phrase de maître
capello mais avant de passer à la phrase
de maître capello retourner auprès de
micheline de dominique sandrine
m'excuser dominique dominique rouits
nous attendons évidemment situation et
robert qui joue et qui essayent de
sélectionner des candidats je leur mets
afficher le mot à lui mais ce monsieur
c'est un coup de sonnette
écoutez bien c'est parti pour deux
minutes robert c on y fait la grêle en
trois lettres ont coup sur le tard voilà
il a gagné le temps il a gagné le
tableau messieurs les sélectionner un
autre candidat s'il vous plaît voilà
on lance un mot de trois lettres encore
au temps suspends ton vol lamartine
deuxième des films ainsi genève en bien
bourget et titicaca slack la classe jury
sélectionne et très bien la vivre aller
vite retrouver jean-pierre dans le
studio un autre candidat
alors attendez je trouve un mot en
quatre lettres
ce n'est pas du stif alors posé de
plâtre fin de show et de craie en huit
ans le marbre pardon vous ne voyez pas
là eh bien c'était stuc stuc un autre
candidat très très vite alors un mot de
sa lettre et crimes de sang des clés
être un mot de cinq lettres écrivain
français prix nobel de littérature en
1957 notre définition syli h devant ces
réalisateurs d'orfeo negro cours et
blanc pardon à camille oui eh bien nous
allons arrêter là notre sélection nous
félicitons nos candidats
merci dominique eddé respire maintenant
tous les candidats sont réunis auprès de
jean-pierre dans le studio
tous les candidats sélectionnés ont
gagné 50 francs et maître nous avons
sélectionné combien de candidats où ils
sont au nombre de sept
au nom de cette candide à bercy m je
leur souhaite bonne chance pour notre
dernier jeu
monsieur madame pardon madame jacques
attendent et nous nous avons encore des
candidats qui pénètrent actuellement
dans notre studio wii est la première
candidate est prête madame c'est à vous
bien madame avant de vous laisser poser
une première question à maître capello
je vous rappelle que sa phrase vaut
aujourd'hui mille francs elle est d'un
auteur connu inscrits quelque part dans
un livre de la bibliothèque de maître
capello et vous n'en connaissez pour
l'instant que les trois mots suivants le
lait et madame nous vous écoutons m 7 1
oui si vous trouvez un mot la phrase
augmente de 1000 francs bon j'aurais
voulu savoir si c'est un auteur très
récent dressant des pôles mots non
madame alors un autre candidat monsieur
yat il ya t'il le mot pays dans la
phrase le mot pays ne peuvent pas un
autre candidat
est ce qu'il y a le mot les olympiques
les led
il est visible les visibles les remet à
ses gants à 2d non il n'y a pas d'autres
articles l'est que celui qu on m'a
l'année monsieur ski à lemont nourrir
nourrir met le verbe nourrir n'y ait pas
un autre excuse émouvant est inscrit
dans la phrase quels mots le mouv en v e
nt ent noël n'y est pas oui encore une
candidate jack oui y'a t'il le mot
printemps pas davantage
merci encore les candidats le nom
jacques je crois que c était d un
candidat s'était terminée et bien nos
candidats n'ont pas à trouver de mots
nouveaux pour la phrase de maître
capello je vous rappelle que pour
l'instant elle vaut toujours mille
francs et je vais demander maintenant à
nos amis s'ils ont eu des petites idées
à nous proposer sur cette phrase avec le
trouvait alors
le concurrent aime les épreuves et les
lauriers c'est pas mal ça doit pas être
anonyme au nom très bien ce genre
moi je vis le le soldat aime les failles
ou la soupe je pense que c'est une
phrase quand même un peu plus relevé
avec sonatrach à se relever
robert non mais la vraie la phrase la
voici le président aime les français les
vacances mais c'est pas mal mais ça
n'est pas du tout est bien ainsi se
termine de nos jeux de 20 heures nous
quittons bordeaux pour ce soir nous
retrouverons d'ailleurs bordeaux demain
et ainsi que toute la semaine et si vous
désirez amis bordelais participer à nos
jeux et bien nous accueilleront demain à
notre station régionale bordeaux
aquitaine 32 rue ulysse gaillon à 13h
donc rendez vous à 13 heures si vous
voulez vous divertir avec nous à la
station régionale et faire 3 bordeaux
aquitaine 32 rue ulysse gaillon je vous
signale que nous jouons demain avec le
mot de passe suivant nous jouons avec le
mot délire vous trouverez ce mot dans
votre journal sud-ouest de demain matin
avec une grille pour vous aider à
rédiger donc d'ores et déjà des mots
issus des lettres issus de sept autres
mots délirants des mots de trois à huit
lettres et apporter les doux à notre
station régionale
encore une fois à 13 heures rendez-vous
donc demain et il me reste maintenant à
vous dire bonsoir à tous bon soir
micheline bonsoir jambes reçoit robert
bonsoir m bonsoir bordeaux à demain
13h30 de rue lise gagnon bonsoir jack
[Musique]